[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN HOLLINGHURST:
Thank you so much.
This novel indeed begins in
the blackout in 1940 in Oxford
and ends up in the
world of Google
and of very different
forms of communication.
It's in five sections, sometimes
with quite large time gaps
in between them.
And I hope part of the
effect of this structure
is that when the reader embarks
on a new section of the book
they're momentarily disoriented.
And it will take them a page or
two to work out where they are,
when they are, and what the
hell's going on generally.
I hope this is also a way
of stimulating the reader's
imagination to try
to speculate as
to what might have
happened during the gaps
between the sections.
A hazard of this structure
is that it's quite
a difficult book to talk
about without giving away
all sorts of important
things about its narrative.
So I get to read an extract
from the very first chapter.
I'll read two extracts, both
from the very first chapter
of the book.
It's in Christ Church,
one of the biggest
colleges in Oxford University.
It's an October evening in 1940.
The blitz is raging in London.
But Oxford, 50
miles from London,
it existed as a strange
remove from all that.
And the conditions
of university life
would be very
changed by the war.
The war has now been
going on for a year.
Students are far fewer.
And those who come
up usually do so,
rather than for an idle three or
four years, for just one year.
They do a short degree.
And after that is the terrible
uncertainty of enlistment
and who knows what future.
But I was rather attracted
to the idea of an Oxford very
altered from the
traditional, literary types
of the city, the kind of
Brideshead idea, if you like,
one in which all
that sets of luxury
has been completely removed.
Various quite important
functions from London
were evacuated to
Oxford in the war.
The war ministry took
over various colleges.
MI5 split its operations in
half into what they coyly
called town and
country And the country
have established itself
at Blenheim Palace just
outside Oxford during the
time that this first part
of the narrative is going on.
The Slade School of
Art, which is normally
part of University
College London,
was also evacuated to Oxford.
So you have this strangely
dislocated and disoriented feel
about the period.
We've had the meeting of
a little literary club who
exists to invite famous writers
to come and read to them.
This section
narrated years later
by the host of
this evening, a man
called Freddie
Green, who because
of some mysterious
condition is actually
exempt from military service
and is beginning his third year.
There's Evert Dax,
who is the son
of a famous author
they've decided
to invite to speak to them.
And Peter Coyle, who is a
rather camp painter of the Slade
School, who's very much
regretting having been shoved
off to Oxford and missing
all the fun in London
during the blitz.
There's something called Charlie
you don't need to worry about.
I think that's probably all
you need to know at this stage.
"Evert and Peter are
looking out of the window
as dusk is falling
across the courtyard.
Peter says, 'Freddie,
have you seen this man?'
'Who is it?'
I went across. 'Oh,
the exhibitionist,
I suppose you mean,' I said.
'No.
Oh, he's gone,' said
Peter, still staring out.
I stood at his shoulder
and stared too.
It was that brief
time between sunset
and the blackout when you could
see into other people's rooms.
Tall panes which had
reflected the sky all day
now glowed companionably
here and there.
And figures were
revealed at work
or moving around behind
the lit grid of the sashes.
In the sets directly
opposite, old Sangster,
the blind French don,
was giving a tutorial
to a young man so supine that
he might have been asleep.
And on the floor above,
beneath the dark horizontal
of the cornice and
the broad pediment,
a single window
was alight, a lamp
on the desk projecting a
brilliant arc across the wall
and ceiling.
'I spotted him the
other day,' I said.
'He must be one of the new men.'
Peter waited with
pretended patience.
And Evert, frowning still, came
back and looked out as well.
Now a rhythmical shadow had
started to leap and shrink
across the distant ceiling.
'Oh, yes, him,' Evert said, as
the source of the shadow moved
slowly into view, a figure
in a gleaming singlet,
steadily lifting and lowering
a pair of hand-weights.
He did so with concentration.
There was no apparent effort.
But of course, it
was hard to tell
at this distance, from which he
showed, in his square of light,
as massive and abstracted, as
if shaped from light himself.
Peter put his hand on my arm.
'My dear,' he said, 'I
seem to have my new model.'
At which Evert
made a little gasp
and looked at him
furiously for a second.
'Well, you'd better
get a move on.'
I said, since these days new men
left as quickly and unnoticed
as they came.
'Even you must by that glorious
head, like a Roman gladiator,
Freddie, said Peter. 'And
those powerful shoulders,
do you see the blue veins
standing in the upper arms?'
'Not without my
telescope,' I said.
I went to fill the kettle
from the tap on the landing
and found Jill Darrow
coming up the stairs.
She was late for the meeting
of the club at which she might
have liked to vote herself.
I was very glad to see her.
But the atmosphere, which
had taken on a hint deviancy,
rather changed when
she came into the room.
She hadn't had the benefit of
10 years in the boys' boarding
school, with all its
ingrained depravities.
I doubt she'd ever
seen a naked man.
Charlie said, 'Ah,
Darrow,' and half stood up,
then dropped back into his chair
with an informality that might
or might not have
been flattering.
'We want Dax to ask
his father to read.'
He said as she removed her
coat and took in who was there.
I set about making the tea.
'Oh, I see,' said Jill.
There was a natural
uncertainty in Evert's presence
as to what could be
said about his father.
At the window, Evert himself
seemed not to know she
had come in.
He and Peter stood staring
up at the room opposite.
Their backs were expressive,
Peter smaller, half thick
and temperamental,
in the patched tweed
jacket which always gave off dim
chemical odors of the studio.
Evert, neat and
hesitant, a strictly
raised boy in an
unusually good suit
who seemed to gaze at pleasure
as at the far bank of a river.
'What are you two staring at?'
Jill said.
'Oh, you mustn't
look,' said Peter,
turning and grinning at her.
At went she went straight to
the window, myself close behind.
The gladiator was still in view,
though now with his back turned
and doing something
with a piece of rope.
I was almost relieved to
see that the scouts had
started their rounds."
The scouts are the
college servants.
"At one window,
and then the next,
the small black-coated
figure appeared, reached up
to close the shutters, and
removed all signs of life.
Across the way the scout
came into Sangster's room,
half-hidden by the
oblong screen he
carried through
into the bedroom,
and after a minute
reappeared, edged
round the two occupants,
and kneeling on the window
seat gazed out for a
curious few seconds
before pulling the
tall shutters too.
By dinner time the
great stone buildings
would be lightless as ruins.
'Ah, Phil,' said Charlie.
Behind us my own scout had
come in to do the same for us.
I said sternly, 'Do you know
who this fellow is, Phil?'
Phil had fought at
the Battle of Loos,
and after that earlier war had
spent 15 years in the Oxford
police.
He was affable and
devoted to the College,
but seemed sometimes to
regret that he had ended up
in an apron, dusting and
washing dishes for young man
he was powerless to discipline.
'What was it, sir?'
He propped his screen
against the wall
and came over eagerly, as
if I'd spotted a miscreant.
I noticed now that
our own reflections
were hanging very
faintly between us
and the view of other windows.
I pointed upwards.
'This ridiculous
fellow,' I said.
'Oh, him, sir," said Phil, a
bit disappointed but trying
for a moment to share
our own interest
in the luminous figure.
'I happen to know there was
a bit of trouble there.'
'What sort of trouble?'
said Peter.
'Well, the noise, sir.
Dr. Sangster's been
complaining about it.' 'Oh?
Said Evert.
'Noise?' 'Rhythmical
creaking, apparently,
sir,' said Phil
with a grim look.
'Oh, goodness," said Evert.
'He's not one of ours,
though, in fact,' said Phil.
'Ah,' I said.
'No, he's one of the
Brasenose men,' said Phil.
In the vast gloomy
College, its staircases
half-deserted since
the start of the War,
new members of
requisitioned colleges
had been slipped in here and
there, disoriented freshmen who
find themselves also evacuees.
Brasenose had been seized by
a ministry of some kind, who
according to my tutor
were rather unsure what
to do with it.
'If you will just
excuse me, Mr. Green?'
'Oh, of course, Phil.'
'You don't happen
to know his name?'
said Jill.
'He's called Sparsholt,
miss, said Phil,
with a small cough as he swung
the shutters to and dropped
the iron bar safely in its slot.
'Sparsholt,' said Peter,
weighing the word and smiling
slyly at Evert.
'Sounds like part of
a engine, or a gun.'
Phil looked at him blankly
for a second or two.
'I dare say you're right,'
he said and went through
into the bedroom.
I sat at my best
Meissen cups, which
I hoped might please Jill,
and in the new closeness
of the panelled
and shuttered room
we settled down to have tea."
That's the first sighting
of young David Sparsholt,
who will cause quite a
flutter amongst this group
of young men.
And in a way, the
consequences of the encounters
that happened in peculiar
conditions of the blackout
in the first part
of the book shape
and, perhaps,
foretell things that
are going to happen
much later on.
David is only 17 at that
time, unlike the others,
who are dreading the future
in all its uncertainties.
Young David Sparsholt can't
wait to get through Oxford
to sign up, join the RAF.
He knows he's going
to have a great war.
He's got it all planned out.
After the war he's
going to go get married.
He's going to set up
an engineering business
and be very successful.
And he does all these things.
I think in this first section
of the book we see him coming
to an understanding
of his own power
at his own power
over other people,
I suppse the quality
of leadership
of being able to get
people to do what you want.
And this power is
also something which
is going to get him into
some quite serious trouble.
And the trouble happens offstage
in the center of the book.
But it permeates a great
deal that happens afterwards.
The second section of the
book, which was set in 1966,
we first meet David
Sparsholt's son, Johnny.
And he emerges, really I
suppose, as the protagonist
of the novel.
And one of the things
I like about writing
about these large
spans of time is
that characters I've imagined
at the beginning move
into center stage later on and
then are themselves, of course,
pushed into the wings.
Johnny is next met in the middle
section of the book, which
takes place in 1974.
He has been to art college.
He's very unlike
his father, in being
sensitive, rather introverted,
responsive to beauty.
And from the first moment we see
him as a boy, he was drawing.
And he's going to go
on to have a career
as a successful
portrait painter.
He's also gay.
And when he comes to London
in 1974 at the age of 22,
he's trying to find
his way through all
the enhanced
possibilities of London
during those years, now seven
years after the Sexual Offenses
Act of 1967 which decriminalized
male homosexuality in England.
But the change in the law
having happened overnight,
the social change is taking
rather longer to permeate.
Anyway, I'm going to
read a scene where
he is taken to
his first gay club
in Earl's Court,
which in those days
was the center of
gay life in London.
And he's going there with a
lesbian couple that he's met.
Francesca, who is very
posh and drinks a lot
and is only once
in her life been
known to take public transport.
And Una, who is a very
large, almost silent,
woman who works in the
cosmetics department of Fenwick,
a famous department
store in old Bond Street.
And Johnny is so smitten
with a young man called Ivan.
And Ivan is attractive and
friendly but rather slippery.
When Johnny thinks something
is about to happen with Ivan,
Ivan sort of wriggles
out of his grasp.
Anyway, Ivan is going
to come and join them
at the club on this evening.
Johnny has been rather
slow to understand
that Ivan is not interested in
people quite as young as him.
So Johnny and Fran
and Una have had
supper in a Chinese
restaurant in Soho.
"'So how are we getting there?'
Johnny said when
they were outside.
He wasn't going to risk
suggesting the bus.
'Taxi,' said Una.
'Or we could take
the Underground.'
He saw his funds for the
evening running awkwardly thin.
'It's probably quicker.'
'Oh, the Underground,' Francesca
stood, in apparent indecision,
gazing at a spot a few
yards away on the pavement,
beneath which she seemed
to picture it running.
'Is it still open?'
Johnny looked at his watch.
It was 10 past 10:00.
'Well, yes,' he said.
And he saw in a moment the Tube
as perhaps she imagined it,
rather than as he knew
it from frequent use,
the deep proletarian labyrinth,
the sort of human sewer,
rumored to underlie
the whole city.
'Oh, but look--' and she ran
a few steps into the road
and somehow caught the eye of
a taxi driver passing the end
of the street, who backed up
and turned and in 20 seconds was
taking her instructions
through the open window.
In the cab, as it swept round
Trafalgar Square and out
into Pall Mall, Johnny had
the uncomfortable but elated
feeling that his London
life had taken off,
not how he'd imagined
it, but the unimagined,
when it happened, had
the bite of authenticity.
The women traveled side by side.
And Johnny sat on
the folding seat
looking at them and past
them, at the vanishing road
and the lights of the vehicles
surging up or dropping behind.
He still felt hungry.
He'd only had one thing
at the little Chinese.
And then the bill
was split three ways
and he couldn't protest.
You ate almost in
the kitchen there,
with the pool splayed
roasted ducks hanging just
above your head like lanterns.
He pushed down the
window an inch.
But the throb of
the engine shivered
it shut in two or three seconds.
Racing backwards towards
his first gay club,
he felt a little queasy.
'This is it,' Francesca
shouted to the driver.
And they stopped at a
narrow white building
on the Earl's Court Road.
A small queue formed outside.
And there was a certain
defiance in showing so plainly
where they were going.
The cabbie looked out wearily.
'You don't want to go in
there, love,' he said to Una.
'It's a poofs' place.'
'Yes, we do,' said Una.
Francesca paid him
and took the change
in full and flapped her
hand in front of her face
as he drove off in a loud
fart of diesel fumes.
Ivan was coming
down the other way,
from the Tube station,
his duffel coat unbuttoned
and the long fringe of
his woollen scarf bobbing
like a sporran
between his thighs.
'Darling!' said Francesca, so
that Johnny didn't seem to know
where he was, after all the
cruel things she said about him
earlier.
Ivan kissed the two girls,
dodged a kiss with Johnny
by butting his head against
the lapel of his coat.
Johnny felt the quick
squeeze of tension,
was anxious and lustful,
watching Ivan unwind his scarf,
and was drunk enough to put
his arm around his shoulders
and leave it there.
He seemed as drunk as they
were, and engaged with the girls
more than with a friend who
was loosely holding him.
'Here we all are
then,' said Francesca,
as they edged a yard
closer to the door.
She winced at Johnny.
'Sorry about this hideous wait.'
At last they went
into the narrow space
inside the door, music audible
now, swing doors beyond
like a cinema and a glimpse when
they opened of the bare room
at the start of a party.
The large man in a bomber
jacket glanced skeptically
at the girls.
'You know this is a
gay club,' he said.
'We've been here thousands
of times,' said Francesca,
looking wanly past him.
'So you're lesbians, are you?'
he said.
'Don't be vulgar,'
said Francesca.
'How you going to prove it?'
said the man.
Francesca sighed
and looked away,
as if dealing with
this kind of person
were quite new indignity.
Then Una, with a hint of a smile
on her large flawless face,
pulled her towards her and
with a tilt of the head started
kissing her with a steady
pushing and chewing
motion which Francesca,
while taking no active part,
made no effort to prevent.
Johnny giggled in amazement
and felt a sudden knot
of excitement that
he and Ivan might
be made to do the same thing.
'Whoa, whoa,' said the bouncer.
But it took him another 10
seconds to separate them.
He looks Johnny and
Ivan up and down.
'Right you are, gentlemen'
he said, and unhitched
the rope for them all.
It turned out you
had to be a member.
Francesca claimed she was, but
this time couldn't prove it.
So they all had to sign a list
and give their address, which
made Johnny uneasy.
He imagined them getting
in touch with his aunt--"
with whom he's
logging at the time--
"and he put a different
number in the street.
It cost 50p each.
'And of course you get your
meal,' said the little Irish
boy in the lit cubbyhole.
Then it was 10p to
leave your coat.
'Should we put ours together,
said Johnny, save money?'
But Ivan said, 'No, it's OK.'"
They go to the club,
they get drinks.
Johnny excitedly, anxiously
checks the place out,
then goes off to buy
some more drinks.
"When Johnny got back
to the table, a fat,
middle-aged man with a
tray was hovering there.
'It's your salads,' he said,
and started unload little bowls
among the bottles and glasses.
Oh, god,' said Francesca.
'I'm not hungry,' said Ivan.
'It's all free.
It comes with your membership,'
said the man, smiling firmly.
'We've already eaten,'
said Francesca.
'It's just your
salads,' he said,
as if a salad were a medicine,
and with the air of someone
used to resistance, for
all his pleasantness.
'You've got to have them.'
He put down four forks
wrapped in paper napkins.
Johnny peered into the
bowls, which each contained
a bit of iceberg lettuce,
a ring of tomato,
and almost hidden, unnamable,
a glistening square of meat.
He sat down when the man
moved on to the next table
and unwrapped a fork.
'Well, I didn't know
we got this,' he said.
'Don't eat it,' said Una.
'No?' said Johnny.
'It's the licensing
law,' said Ivan.
'They have to serve a meal.'
This seemed to Johnny both
absurd and quite fortunate.
He was more hungry now than he'd
been before dinner and food was
here, the shameful stopgap
of the boozing student.
'Well, doesn't look too bad.'
And with the others
gazing at him,
and then thinking it better
to resume their conversation,
he ate his lettuce and tomato,
there was no dressing on it,
and popped in the pink-grey
tongue-sized piece of meat.
Which he chewed
uncertainly, thinking it
was probably ham,
prepacked, sweaty,
and with a knot of
gristle in it he
had to bring out behind
his hand and hide
in the bowl under his
screwed up napkin.
It was dismaying, and connected
in a momentary violence
of image with the glazed
squashed ducks earlier.
Sometimes meat disgusted him.
He took a swig from
his cold beer bottle.
Ivan raised an eyebrow
into his fringe
and gestured to his own bowl.
'Have mine,' he said.
'No thanks,' said Johnny.
'Or, well, actually--' and
switching the two bowls,
he ate Ivan's salad too.
It only took a minute,
smiling defiantly
as he chewed and thought of
other things of Ivan's he'd
like.
And when that was
done, the thing
with the force now of
some future anecdote,
he pulled Una's salad towards
him, and polished it off.
He rested.
He felt some natural deferences
as he looked at Francesca.
Then he smirked.
And she said, 'What?
Oh, go on,' waving her hand over
the bowl as she turned her head
in mingled amusement
and disgust."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: We're going to
open it up to questions now.
I guess I'll just kick off the
discussion with a question.
I was wondering
if you could talk
more about your inspiration
for this novel and the choice
to center it around a sex
scandal that reverberates
over seven decades.
ALAN HOLLINGHURST:
Well I think that was
one of the ideas of the early
parts of this book and indeed
for quite a long time afterward.
If gay life emerged
into the news,
it was generally in
the form of a scandal.
In a time when
homosexuality was illegal,
there was something inherently
scandalous about it as a topic.
So it interested
me to try and write
not about the scandal, the
mechanics of the scandal
itself, but about its impact.
We don't actually learn
about the Sparsholt affair,
the scandal that David Sparsholt
is involved in until eight
years after it's happened.
And I think I rather wanted
to create that sense that one
has of something which
has been displayed
to the prurient public and
news media some time ago
and the details of which
are now rather faded.
Because Sparsholt is
a very unusual name.
When people meet young
Johnny eight years later,
they do a little double take
when they hear who he is.
And they think, oh, you must
be related to David Sparsholt.
But they can't precisely
remember what happened.
And I wanted to create
the sense of the scandal
as a sort of lingering,
slowly fading, stain.
As it's one which has a
significant gay element in it,
it's something
which rather presses
on Johnny's own
consciousness as he's
trying to forge his
way as a an out gay man
and doing something which,
in his father's case,
had been very publicly
punished and stigmatized.
So that was certainly
one of the initial ideas.
Another was getting very
interested in Oxford
during the war.
A very dear old
friend of mine, who
actually died at the
end of last year,
had been an undergraduate at
Christ Chuch during the war
and reminisced to
me a lot about it.
And I thought it was
fascinating that very changed,
the unusual conditions of
that period, very little
written about.
The only other novel that I've
come across such in Oxford
during the Second World
War is an early novel
by Philip Larkin called
"Jill," which I pirated wildly
for useful details
when writing this.
But it's tricky writing
this kind of book.
And my previous book,
"The Strangest Child,"
covered an even longer period,
I think nearly 100 years
starting before
the First World War
and ending up in
2008 or something.
I think it's that
the idea of following
the consequences of actions over
a large period at the same time
as dramatizing the quite
predictable changes
and surprises of time.
As we get older, we
reinterpret the past.
The workings of
memory, which is really
a novelist's main resource, I
find more and more fascinating.
But if you are writing
a book in five episodes
covering a wide
period, in a way,
you're starting from five
different starting points.
It's a hard work
way of doing it.
And it makes me always feel that
I've written five short novels
in one, each of
which had to have
its own imaginative genesis,
even though they all link up.
But they link up
at bleak angles.
In "The Strangest Child,"
the first section,
which was set in
1913, just takes place
over one weekend where some
very ambiguous events happen
concerning a young poet
who was killed in the war.
And in a way, all of the later
four sections of the book
are all glosses on that
initiating weekend.
In this book I think the
structure's rather different.
And the sections are connected
to each other more indirectly.
And both books do
something which interests
me more and more, which
is avoiding resolution
and explanation, the sort of
classic model, which I suppose
is the model of a detective
story or something,
of a novel enshrining a
secret which is explained just
before the end, after
which everything suddenly
makes sense.
And I think I did do that in
the first two novels I wrote.
But it seems to be increasingly
that life's not like that.
And actually the experience
of living and getting older
is one in which more and more
things are never understood,
never fully explained.
So I've been quite
interested in trying
to create a large
fictional structure
in which I hope each
part of the narrative
is seductive and
interesting and amusing
but which overall doesn't settle
into a clear, resolved shape.
And it's a risky thing.
But it does seem
to be worth doing.
AUDIENCE: In
writing about a book
that takes place in five
different time periods,
how do you ensure
that you're faithful
to the style of
conversation and dialogue
in each of the
different time periods?
And how do you also
ensure that whatever
style you've written
for one era doesn't
bleed through to
another era in the book?
ALAN HOLLINGHURST: I worried
about that a lot more
in "The Strangest Child,"
going back into the pre
World War period.
I think the bulk of this book,
with the second section set
in 1966 when I was 12,
the bulk of the book
actually happens
during my lifetime
and during periods where I feel
pretty confident of the idioms
and so forth.
The earlier things
require more care.
I mean, I rely on the
Oxford English dictionary
online a great deal for finding
when words and usages, phrases
and so on were first recorded.
Anachronisms, even if
only evident to a few
sharp eared people,
spoil things.
So you've go to to get it right.
So obviously, you
don't introduce
any kind of figurative language,
which alludes to things which
would happen after the period.
If you're writing about periods
before your own lifetime,
its struck me very much
writing these things set
in 1913 and 1926 in
my previous book what
sort of knowledge
of those periods
is irreducibly literary.
And my sense of how people
spoke and conducted themselves
mainly, I suppose, comes from
reading novels written recently
in that period or seeing perhaps
not completely reliable films
of them and also
being very interested
in the literary history, reading
letters and diaries and so
on of the period.
And I think I've got
a reasonably good ear
for the period tone.
But I very much value detail
editorial scrutiny of it.
I think I shouldn't have
had done the picking up.
Anachronisms creep in so easily.
And you can be quite
mistaken in your belief
as to when something happened.
In the draft, the
version of this
which almost went to print, I
had people being paid in euros
five years before
euros were introduced.
[INAUDIBLE] They'd
stopped to that point.
So there's an element
of research in it.
And often one just Googles it.
Research is now so easy.
I always feel it's too easy.
I think there is a
way that research
can sort of shriek
research, actually,
when you're reading a
novel particularly set
on the historical period.
And I certainly read
historical fiction
in which everything
that you see is
described in great detail
in where it came from
and how much it cost.
It's obviously someone has
just been researching it.
But actually, the
superabundance of period detail
oddly undermines the
naturalness and convincingness
of the historical account.
You want to get that sense
of people living in the past
as we all do, with no
knowledge of the future
and no sense of how
tremendously quaint
we're all going to
look in 50 years' time.
And I think that's
something I try to capture
in writing about the past.
AUDIENCE: I'd be
curious hearing you
talk some more about other ways
in which your interests have
evolved since your first
novel through your career.
ALAN HOLLINGHURST: Yes, gosh.
But I can see there's
some interests which
have remained constant.
When I set out to write my
first book, "The Swimming Pool
Library," which I starting
writing on January 1st, 1984,
I had a very clear idea of
writing a book about gay life
in England, which I hadn't
noticed anybody else writing.
And that was then 17 years
off of the Sexual Offenses Act
had been passed.
But again, it's an example
of that rather slow grasping
of the new freedoms
which this represented.
When I was a graduate
student, I did work
on gay writers
like E.M. Forster,
who hadn't been
able to write openly
about their sexuality in
their work and the effects
that this might
have had on them.
And this was a quite
new topic at the time.
And it's hard to always
re-enter the mental conditions
of earlier periods and
to remember just what one
knew and didn't know.
But certainly
through the 70s there
was this deepening, widening
interest in gay history
and a good deal of outing,
sometimes rather wishful,
outing of figures for the past.
And it was a fascinating moment.
And I think I felt part of
that when I started writing
"The Swimming Pool Library."
And it was very
determinedly a gay book.
And it was tremendous fun
to do and rather a risk
and created a great
deal of anxiety
on the part of its publishers.
But happily, it was a success.
What I wanted to do in that
book, one of the things
I wanted to do, was just to
write from a gay position
without any kind of
explanation or apology
and just to do so as naturally
as most writers write
from a straight point of view.
And then I took that
as my basis thereafter.
But of course, that first
book was about all sorts of--
it wasn't just about people
being madly gay the whole time.
It was about them--
actually, it was
mostly about that.
But it was full of a
lot of other interests.
I think I've slowly
broadened the social canvas
in my third shortest
novel, "The Spell."
It was a novel about four
gay men and their rather
complicated interrelations.
But with "The Line of
Beauty," my fourth book,
I felt I was entering
wider territory.
And it's essentially
about and all seen
through the eyes
of a young gay man.
But a lot of the world that he's
moving in is not by any means
a gay one.
So I thought he would
be an interesting lens
on the world of the mid 80s,
the boom years of Mrs. Thatcher
and the conservative
triumph in that period,
just something which this
clever young man is rather
slow to really understand.
And I think with "The Strangest
Child," as I was saying,
the whole thing has opened up.
And there's a lot more
time and there's a lot more
of these big gaps in it.
And questions of memory become
more and more important.
And the openly erotic
elements of the book
are rather less, something
which a lot of reviewers
complained about.
And I think those are my
main preoccupations now.
When "The Line of Beauty" won
the Booker Prize, of course
it was journalistically
categorized as a gay book.
"Daily Express"
even said gay sex
wins Booker, which is a version
of the prize we've yet to see.
But I think my last two
books haven't really
been categorized in that way.
And actually, I
feel that there was
something which I was part of.
There was the rise of a
specifically gay literature
really through the
80s and 90s, when
they were responding first
of all to liberation and then
to the great unforeseen
crisis of AIDS and so on
and the immense
social changes that
have happened since I started
writing that first book
and published it
exactly 30 years ago.
I'm not responding
to the same pressures
or feeling the urgency of
that material in the way
that I used to.
It's hard for me in a way
to describe my own progress
or evolution or whatever it is.
And it may be something
which is oddly more apparent
to the reader than it is to me.
I feel too inside it.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes when
I speak to younger people,
I have to remind myself that
no one under the age of 40
has any significant
memory of Ronald Reagan
or Margaret Thatcher
or the Soviet Union
or any of the things
that many of us
would consider fundamental.
I'm wondering about your
reactions and observations
about younger
people who were born
pretty much after the whole--
well, certainly well
after the Sexual Offenses
Act-- but after much of
the revolution in attitudes
towards homosexuality and all
of the activism everything
else that was required
to bring that about.
But certainly
younger people really
have no personal experience
of that, and in a sense,
I would think grow up in
a world with fundamentally
different attitudes.
And I'm wondering how you
experience that and see
that when you talk
to younger people.
And do they respond to your
books in a different way?
ALAN HOLLINGHURST:
They probably do, yes.
I'm very struck by it myself.
I remember when the film of "The
Line of Beauty" was being made
and young Dan Stevens had to
dance with Kika Markham playing
Mrs. Thatcher.
He really didn't have any
knowledge of Mrs. Thatcher.
We'd moved on so far.
And I think, yes, the lack of
a consciousness of the AIDS
crisis is one which strikes
people of my generation
very forcibly.
And young people generally
are awfully rather astounded
when you tell them about it.
And the medical situation
is so different now.
There seems to be
an alarming increase
in the uptake of sexually
transmitted diseases
and so on amongst young people.
On the other hand,
one doesn't want
them to be burdened with this.
I think the whole
question of learning
about the history of your own
kind if you're a gay person
is a very fascinating one.
And it sort of was the
model for my first book,
"The Swimming Pool
Library," in a way,
which was a pre-AIDS book.
But the 25-year-old narrator
falls in with this much older
man, a man in his 80s.
And by reading his journals,
he makes his little visits
into gay life in early
periods of the century.
And it gives him the
opportunity to learn some
of the history of his own kind.
And I think it's
one reason that I've
been quite interested in
writing books in which there are
strong intergenerational
relationships between older
and younger men, the older
man often acting as a mentor
or educator of the young
one, who may in turn act
as a refresher to the older one.
I'm so far out of the
world of education
that I don't know to what extent
the history of the gay movement
and so on would figure in an
ordinary secondary education
today.
Perhaps not much.
It's very good in a way, that
in large areas of our culture,
it's rather cool
too big to be queer.
It's a subject which
never stays still.
And that's one of the things
that fascinates me about it.
And so rather than
defining themselves
as we used to in the
past, there seems
to be so much more elasticity
about the idea of sexuality
now.
And I think that's, perhaps
in a way, been reflected
in what I've been writing myself
and being much more interested
in sexual ambiguities.
Una and I have got young
friends in their 20s
who call themselves non-binary.
I grope-- that's perhaps
not the right word--
grapple slightly with
these new subcategories.
That's rather ideal in a way, if
there's this degree of freedom
to explore your sexuality.
I gave you a rather rambly
answer to your question.
I find myself as a novelist
repeatedly drawn back
to these earlier
periods when being gay
was more challenging
in social, legal terms.
But I would far
rather be living now.
I'm very conscious,
too, that one is always
speaking about this western,
in my case, generally
metropolitan culture and that
in other parts of the world,
things are not getting
better for anybody
who wants to explore their
sexuality but dramatically
worse.
And I have a number of friends
from equatorial Africa,
for instance, who've
had to flee from Uganda
or Cameroon for their lives and
whose efforts to do anything
to protect the rights
of sexual minorities
in those countries have
led to intimidation,
violence, and so forth.
Through a lot of
Eastern Europe, there
are similar things going on.
And I think we feel in a
period of political reaction
like this, all those hard
won freedoms of the past
might themselves, again,
come under attack.
So in that sense, an
education in this history
will be doubly valuable
for the young people.
AUDIENCE: I wonder
if you could talk
a bit more about how you arrived
at the structure of this novel.
Was it always five stories?
Or did things change from
your original conception of it
as you worked on it?
ALAN HOLLINGHURST: It was
a bit harder in the shaping
than anything I'd
done before, actually.
And I think I did have a desire
to write something slimmer.
I'm absolutely dying
to write a short novel.
I just don't seem to
have a short novel in me
unfortunately.
I was reluctant
to first replicate
the five part structure.
But I arrived at it
after some struggle.
I didn't start writing chapter
as it were until I had,
I never do, until I had the
sense of the whole thing.
So by that stage, I'm pretty
clear about the structure.
And it's hard for
me now to retrace
exactly the different stages
of decision or the indecision
around the planning of the book.
I knew there would
be the war time.
I would only be
waffling if I tried
to say exactly how the plans
finally fitted together.
I knew I wanted it to turn in
a way at the end which perhaps
my books generally haven't.
And I think this book has a
more open and even optimistic
ending to it.
Normally I enjoy exercising
the novelist prerogative
to push his characters off a
cliff at the end of the book
or to plunge them into
some deep uncertainty.
But this I think he has a
more benign ending to it.
And the last two
sections of the book
are called Losses,
which is reflects
that period in everyone's
life when suddenly you're
going to as many funerals
as you are parties.
But the last section
is called Consolations.
And it moves into a
further age of slightly
surprising new possibilities
of happiness and so forth.
And I can't quite
remember when that--
I think that was quite a later
idea that it would actually
end more gently.
AUDIENCE: So that last
comment intrigued me,
because you said that in
your more recent books
you've wanted to
have more ambiguity.
But it sounds like
you've seen also this one
and has a more benign ending.
Do you think that's related?
That because there's more
ambiguity in the story
that also you felt
freer to leave
the people in a happier place?
ALAN HOLLINGHURST:
Possibly, yes.
Yes, there are so many
uncertainties about the book.
Nothing it in I think is simple.
I wanted to create an
image of everybody's lives
being lived eventually in terms
of some kind of compromise,
adjustment to what has happened,
making the most of what
you can, dealing with a
life changing scandal,
dealing with the
loss of loved ones.
And Johnny himself,
I didn't want
him to be an exemplary
heroic artist battling
against philistines
or something.
He actually is doing
this strange thing
of being a portrait painter,
where he can obviously
deploy his own skills and
instincts as an artist
but is also necessarily working
to please the people who are
sitting for him, paying him.
So it's a strange compromise
form of artistic activity.
So everything is sort of
qualified and complicated.
I think that was the
sense I hoped to convey.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks very much
again, everybody, for coming.
And thank you so much, Alan,
for talking to us today.
ALAN HOLLINGHURST:
It's been a pleasure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]